at o stone asks bro how is coral an
animal what what hits jay oh hitting a
joint so do you want me to say that i'm
biologist and author tor hansen today
i'll be answering your questions from
twitter this is biology support part two
[Music]
auntpaulrizzo28 asks hashtag wild earth
do ostriches really hide their head in
the sand
no
they don't it's a myth and no one's
quite sure where that myth came from
although there are certain displays that
male ostriches do during the breeding
season where they get down on the ground
and move their heads back and forth and
sway and show off their amazing plumage
but at no point do they actually bury
their head in the sand
ice dancer ben asks how do ticks latch
on like that well if you ever get a
chance to look closely at the mouth of a
tick you will be horrified they have two
little knife-like blades that cut in to
the flesh and then something that looks
like a tongue but with all of these
barbs on it so that when it's inserted
it cannot be pulled out easily again and
that's just the beginning the saliva of
ticks includes an anticoagulant that
prevents your blood from clotting it
includes something to make your blood
vessels expand so that more blood comes
to the wound and it includes an
analgesic a painkiller so that you won't
feel a thing in fact the ability of
ticks through their bite and their
saliva to overcome our defenses is one
of the reasons that so many diseases
like lyme's disease take advantage of
ticks they are freeloaders relying on
the ways that ticks overcome our
defenses and giving those disease
organisms a free entry point into our
bodies
amanda smith says weird biology question
do female mammals get a monthly period
or do they just get their periods during
the mating season the answer is that
most female mammals don't get a period
at all menstruation as we know it in
homo sapiens is actually very rare in
mammals known just from our species and
mostly a few other primates and they
have a cycle that is called estrus which
can occur every few days in something
like a mouse or only a few times a year
in many of the larger mammals they
reabsorb the uterine lining rather than
shedding it at
ftblk woman asks does salt really hurt
slugs or is that some cartoon [ __ ] the
answer is it really does hurt the slugs
if you've ever left a salt shaker out in
a humid environment you might have
noticed that the salt tends to cake up
that's because salt is very good at
absorbing moisture and a slug is more or
less like a bag of moisture so when you
salt a slug the salt dehydrates the slug
it draws the water out of the skin
desiccates the slug and kills it
at harry hoover asks how do murder
hornets work do you just give them a
list so murder hornets have been in the
headlines lately because they are
recently arrived in north america they
are an asian species the asian giant
hornet and it's believed that they
jumped over the pacific ocean not on
their own wings but in shipping
containers arriving probably in the port
of vancouver in british columbia and
over the border into the state of
washington well i happen to have
murder hornets right here in all three
phases of their life cycle the larva the
pupa and the adult and we focus most of
our attention on the adult because
they're large and scary and have a
potent sting but in a lot of ways the
trouble starts right here with the larva
because if you can imagine a nest a
colony of murder hormones with hundreds
or even thousands of these giant grubs
that are hungry all the time it's quite
a job for the adults and they have
developed then a particular strategy
that sets them apart they target other
social insects like honeybees or paper
wasps where if they can succeed in
overcoming the colony they can find a
huge amount of food in one place to take
back to feed to the kids back home and
that strategy has led them to evolve
this large body size with extremely
thick
exoskeletons that can withstand the
stingers of the insects that they're
attacking so it really is the
responsibility of the adults to feed the
young that has driven their evolution to
be so large and scary in the first place
at jake vigg asks what's the weirdest
animal platypus excluded in biology we
don't necessarily think about animals as
weird but we are very interested in the
marvelous adaptations that some animals
come up with so when we're talking about
finding strange ones we look in extreme
places my favorite of these weird
environments and odd creatures has to do
with the carcasses of whales what we
call whale falls when they sink to the
bottom of the ocean and create their own
little ecosystem and there are zombie
worms that have evolved specifically to
devour the bones of whales but they do
so without mouths they excrete an acid
that dissolves the bones of the whales
and they live alongside bacteria that
help transfer the nutrition from those
dissolved bones inside the worm itself
so in biology if you want to find
strange creatures look in strange places
at o stone asks bro how is coral an
animal it's jay so a coral is an animal
a tiny animal with a mouth and with
little tentacles that reach out and grab
food from the water not all together
dissimilar from something like a
barnacle but where a barnacle lives
alone corals live in colonies of
thousands of clone-like individuals and
they take on elaborate shapes to get
themselves up off the ocean floor into
the water column to feed but also to
allow the dinoflagellates or algae that
live alongside them to photosynthesize
because the little coral polyps get some
nutrition from the photosynthesis going
on in their symbiotic algae and that's
why many corals take on shapes that
resemble plants they're trying to
increase the surface area of their
structures so that more photosynthesis
can take place and we all have a
connection a surprising connection to
corals and other shell-making creatures
in everyday life that's because when
their shells break down in the ocean
particularly in shallow tropical seas
where corals and shell makers are very
very common those sediments harden into
limestone which we then later mine to
produce
cement
and you can track the course of the
shell into the cement by looking for
something called calcium carbonate which
is the main component of shells and is
found in cement as well and you can do
so with the addition of hydrochloric
acid which dissolves that calcium
carbonate producing bubbles of carbon
dioxide alongside water you can see it
in the shell
and you can see it
in the cement which means of course that
surprisingly enough even in our most
built environments we're never really
that far from a tropical beach
atkin kaiju 8 asks hashtag botany
biology question for all you
plant-centric scientists are there any
plants with pleasant common names but
are instead deadly and or toxic the
answer is yes and i happen to have
the seeds of one of them right here
these come from a plant pleasantly
enough called the rosary pea and it is
in the pea family and they do use these
beautiful black and red seeds to make
rosaries and other forms of jewelry but
the plant is deadly deadly toxic one
seed well chewed is enough to kill a
person at fauna grace asks do bowls
really hate the color red the answer is
no they don't hate the color red they
can't even see the color red you could
irritate a bowl with a polka dot cape or
a brown cape just as easily it is the
motion that attracts their attention the
color red was chosen one because it's
showy and it may please the audience and
two for a more grisly purpose it hides
the bloodstains that the injured bull
might leave as it passes underneath at
jpetrue97 asks for viruses the goal is
to continue to spread and manufacture by
utilizing a host what good is a dead
host therefore is there any reason to
believe covid would mutate to be more
deadly as opposed to more transmissible
but less deadly well the short answer is
yes we expect that a virus over its
history in a population will eventually
mutate into something less deadly and
very transmissible because that is in
the best interest of the virus itself
but of course mutations are random
events so there is still the chance that
covid or other viruses particularly when
they are new in a population to have a
mutation that produces something more
severe
at hobvacore asks are the cells of an
elephant bigger than the cells of a rat
explain why or why not well the answer
is no there are limits to how big a cell
can grow whether it's in a rat or an
elephant because cells like any living
thing they need fuel and they produce
waste and the way that they get those
things into and out of the cell is
through a process called diffusion so if
you get too large of a cell it becomes
inefficient and you can't get the stuff
all the way into the middle of the cell
where it is required interestingly
enough one of the only creatures out
there to get around that limitation of
diffusion is a particular group of very
small organisms certain bacteria that
have developed bubbles if you will
within the cell called vacuoles that
push all of the essential parts of the
cell closer to that cell wall allowing
the cell to grow larger and still be
serviced by the process of diffusion
from the outside so are the cells of an
elephant larger than the cells of a rat
the answer is no
at islandfangirl1 asks why will a mother
bird abandon its chick if touched by a
human well the answer is they don't
that's a common myth many studies that
use tagging of young birds rely on going
to the nest applying a small tag to the
bird and then of course returning it to
the nest and allowing the mother to
raise that bird to maturity now that's
not to say we should all go out and
start touching baby birds but it does
point out that most birds have a very
high loyalty to their eggs and to their
chicks while they're raising them and
even if those nests are disturbed by us
or by a potential predator or what have
you the adult birds will most likely
return and finish the job at alamedamark
asks question for biologists is there
any other species that attacks its own
species as frequently as humans do the
answer is yes there are all sorts of
species that attack members of their own
species in nature consider the praying
mantis where the female will happily
decapitate the male after copulation and
eat the male to provide a free meal and
more energy for raising up her brood of
eggs or consider lingcods and various
fishes that are perfectly happy to eat
smaller individuals of their own species
they choose their meals by size not by
whether or not they're related but if we
want to look for examples of planned
attacks in nature it helps to look at
one of our closest relatives the
chimpanzees who are known to organize
raids from one neighboring band to
another neighboring band with the
express purpose of finding isolated
individuals and attacking them and even
killing them that is a grisly behavior
but one that we can look upon with some
familiarity because we see it in our own
species
at elmo's twitter asks question for
biologists is it possible to bring back
extinct species if so how hashtag
biology extinction really is for the
most part forever that said there are
efforts underway to bring back
certain species that have
dna preserved in a frozen state
for example woolly mammoths where there
is at least some recognizable dna in the
carcasses that are still available
in the frozen tundras of the far north
so there is some sort of jurassic park
style biology going on to bring back
some of those species however there are
situations where species go extinct in
the wild but then can be reintroduced
later after some sort of captive
breeding project one of the most
exciting to entomologists at least
examples of this has to do with a
creature called the tree lobster a giant
stick insect found on lord howe island
in the tasman sea and considered extinct
for over a century until a few dozen
individuals were found eeking out a tiny
existence on a rocky spire just off the
coast they were gathered they were bred
in captivity and they now number in the
thousands and biologists are just
waiting for the day they can reintroduce
them to lord howe island after they
eradicate the rats that got them into
trouble in the first place at your
friend tina asks why is wildlife
conservation as a career kinda looking
sexy rn well is it looking sexy that's
great news for wildlife conservationists
the field of wildlife conservation may
appear sexy or may appear booming to you
right now because it's more important
than ever before as wild areas and
natural areas and biodiversity diminish
the role of conserving what's left
becomes more and more important and we
do have some success stories to look to
and to inspire us as well consider for
example the california condor nearly
extinct decades ago so rare that the
last few individuals were trapped from
the wild bred in captivity for decades
and are now slowly being released back
in to their former habitat flying over
northern california places where their
huge wingspans have been missing for
decades so those are all the questions
we have for today a wonderful mixture of
questions by the way thank you for
watching biology support